مقترحات ساذجه كلينيكيه وخطيره في الوقت
نفسه جزء من انتقادات وجهات لخطط زعيم حزب
العمال البريطاني المرجو منها حل ازمه
الخدمات الصحيه حيث حذر خبراء الصحه من
اخطر احد المقترحات والمتمثل بالسماح
للمرضى باحاله انفسهم للعلاج دون العوده
لطبيب فزعيم حزب العمال العمال اقترح عدم
الحاجه لمساعده متخصصه في حال الام الظهر
او وجود نزيف او غيرها بل الرجوع الى
الذات اطباء ان بريطانيون ابدو قلقهم من
تحول التشخيص الطبيب الذاتي على الانترنت
او ما يعرف دكتور جوجل لمشكله اكبر في
بريطانيا كما اكدوا انه ان للتشخيص الخاطئ
تاثير معاكس قد يزيد طوابير المنتظرين
امام المستشفيات للحصول على الرعايه
متخصصه صحيه في الاطار نفسه مشاهدينا
استطلاع راي بداته صحيفه ذا تايمز منذ اكد
انهيار ثقه نور في الخدمات الصحيه فسنان
من كل ثلاثه بريطانيين يعتقدون ان الخدمات
المقدمه من هيئه الصحه البريطانيه سيئه
للغايه
[موسيقى]